[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I am Mike McCarty on here with
Lucy James hey and I am also here with
Yasuhiro and Robert from secure Oh
shadows die twice which was just I don't
know T's last year but revealed this
week
how's it feel feels fantastic I think so
yeah ravenous yeah thanks for joining us
I'm personally very very excited for
this one from software a legendary
designer developer I'm very very excited
to dive into this so tell us about steak
hero so sick you know shadows die twice
is as you know the newest game from from
software it is a third-person
action-adventure game with RPG elements
it's set in the late 1500s Japan time
period and that we call the Sengoku or
warring States period that said it is
definitely not a history game in any way
whatsoever it is a original world
created by from software that pulls on
themes from that time frame so you're
gonna see a lot of things that didn't
really exist
yeah yeah so obviously from software has
a very distinct style to their games
obviously like people are there's
there's games that are taking after them
whether it's like Lords the Fallen or
the surge or neo there are games that
are like it's carved out its own people
are calling it like in Chandra now right
assuming in what ways is sacred Roe
going to kind of allude to From
Software's past I'll let you tell us on
I assume that one what kind of myself I
thought I thought I know yeah I know
because you know oh my son Shaw City of
God doctor hang or enzyme are
immortalized a mask on off he come kind
of hyper money mode motorized a mascot
you know I saw this name okay at Oh
momma's la prima donnas yoni mikekim was
cast there the Sabra uini
toss second considered a new game de
totora must come up tonight on who knows
section with me mechanics no viscous
week at all I gotta say Kannada game at
all
you know this time also is one thing
that is similar as it's gonna be really
hard but at the same time they're also
shooting for that feeling of achievement
that you get when you when you overcome
something difficult and it's like the
Monica meetable tonight you on a
boastful car I know unique and a big
talker McCrory over there are no solar
cities in developed are so Thomas in the
Baltimore Macomb come out all the way
there what I tell you in a motel right
you're gonna see things they with buses
that they've you've never seen before
you're going to be fighting with you're
going to have weapons and fight in ways
that you've never seen before
there's a lot of things in here that are
going to be very surprising for fans we
can't wait for them to see it so
typically in in from software games
you're dropped into this world and
you're given very vague hints about the
world and the law and what you you as a
person as a player is supposed to be
doing are we gonna be experiencing the
same thing with secure like it seems
like even from the opening trailer
there's certainly more of a plot point
for us to follow there's a goal for us
straight away there I've just
storytelling ordinary master show this
now know a cool guy mother submit a
Lucia not coconut in jaga Mamoru Becky
are zo doc can stare if Chris you had a
sneaky I te gustó hottest appear ma
story no Matty Mara Aramis yeah as you
were mentioning like those early themes
are pretty clear so the you know the
hero has had his master captured he
needs to go back and get him he also
needs to take revenge for the guy that
cut off his arm right so it's it does
start out clearly there but what am I
the only more chopped or you know do
what courier see it so it the story you
know on Altamaha Aramis and so yeah
that's a lot probably you know
comparatively easier to understand
they're beginning just as you said tada
oh no Priya no pretty god no so no story
in in a particular school kappa yo and
rt+ our holy mother Caligari ma same
right but that experiential
storytelling experience where you know
the story is told by you it's born in
the world
that's unchanged that's that's still
there as it always has been so so the
reporting of every item description
Titan description minista mellitus now
at wah
max winter Treaty more mama you know
sync oh ho ho toka mo geodesy tanzaku
took a more mahomes even know story it's
good people Addison not only must know
their music so you can definitely look
forward to that
additionally the the map has a lot to
explore right um some oh yeah and it's
seamlessly interconnected all throughout
so there's a lot to find in there he
can't wait for people players to see it
in terms of like being seamlessly
integrate is there gonna be any kind of
like a bonfire or lamp system in order
to help players get around bonfire
taking our system our mascot I thought
you had a checkpoint to meet item Anwar
I know you autumn update their quarry
corrupt you can't disclose name they are
planning on implementing some sort of
his checkpoint system however they have
not they're not talking in detail about
it yet okay it's actually just not
finally don't tell you the wrong thing
so by the way I have you guys played the
are you guys friends of this whole
series yeah okay good to know
yeah absolutely and I'm curious when it
comes to the combat of sacred oh we've
seen some during the Microsoft
conference and the b-roll we have but um
can you talk about how the combat of
sacred row will be you know set apart
from blood-borne dark zones etc just in
Toronto gotcha I must correct so listen
I know Cora marrett wha uh no kickball
salsa con mucha don't check out they
they're at puma punku mo has emitted
vivid or Sabatini capo SolarCity that
wasn't super yeah picked on their own Oh
taka taka equipo con tiny talks about
the Motown scat all major major cinemas
to finish to them or polymer addendum
sauce ahumada Scott they couldn't
they're all Amador in your horizon so
the way it feels as it controls
it feels kind of familiar and then when
you start getting into it you start to
realize it's extremely different so as a
Souls veteran the first time he picked
it up he was like he fought it for a
couple anyways he was like oh yeah I got
this is easy and then he just got rekt
he said it you know then while there is
a familiarity there's a lot of it's it's
just a completely different control and
feel not only when it comes to the
combat but also the traversal it seems
like we've got a grappling hook there's
a lot more movement jumping can you talk
about implementing that into the game I
know buddy talking about God oh did I
come see you at the Korean oh sorry oh
ma
give me it mark you to Castle Road is so
serene all right
don't kick and Astarte on [ __ ] so listen
Oh Missoula Karuma demo baklava map to
lessness the title in it could take
their this Oreo tanzaku that emotional
initio to who knee on what the coumadin
could pick my son you know verticality
has always been a important part of
their design like having you know in all
games they would use ladders or
something like that and you would go up
up and down all over the place so no car
you know on your pair see sign is
totally tidy genome app or the tidy
guinea tanzaku it also record over my
dynamic you need also to go the human
right but with the grappling hook you
can actually now you don't need to you
don't need to use those ladders you can
actually just boom go there so it
changes a lot in the way that you
explore the world in the way that they
design the maps it's very different
sento dokodemo
sky MSC oh no map no yo doc a doctor
know about we need to we're gonna do
ticket era Sakuni keaney
donde they're toxic Kogi Keo Sarat oh
god no
dictating innocent autonomic
announcements right it also allows for
interesting verticality in combat so
let's say there's a sniper about a Ledge
and you can use the grappling hook to
get there you can actually fly there do
a roll and hit him and take them out
it's just a fly wasn't the right word
you can grapple hook there but yeah you
get there a lot more options in battle
as well
auditory era no naka de votantes kodomo
no no no money no Peter Hickey knee
socks it
how you know or chicagee they thought
about the over the model bath so I got
them all you only started them and you
may have noticed in the trailer but in
it the hair actually uses a grappling
hook and and goes to the boss yeah it
doesn't attack there as well so there
are times where you can do this as well
so this is the boss who is puking on his
sword to give it poison damage or
something it looked like very Souls born
thing to son all I saw someone I know
right
Oh God height they must up again no no
[ __ ] you all sort of sake this carnal
thoughts Caputo sake took up our Eva
tokuma tonight amazing they're imagining
it's either sake or potentially poison
okay yes that that was what you were
seeing there yeah it's a little bit
about the arm yeah very interesting how
does that roll into the gameplay so I
can I can talk to that one Jackie
founder of geese you know close my
bullets about it so the prosthetic arm
is it has to he uses one as you know
it's a grappling hook we've already
discussed it also has a variety of tools
that you can equip to it some of them
you can use to attack directly like that
axe you saw on the trailer where you
just boom you hit enemies and then
others have a special use such as
firecrackers that you can use to blind
enemies as an example and you pair that
with your right hand
so that's your left hand you pair that
with your right hand which is the katana
and you kind of use them together well
you know using multiple tools over here
you're fighting with the sword at the
same time and you're kind of combining
them together you have combos with with
them and there's a lot of different
interesting ways they can be combined
right so add to that the grappling hook
you have like some jump flippin
mechanics that you may have seen as well
there's a lot o and stealth there's a
lot you can do in this game and then I
with Dark Souls obviously is more you
know gothic medieval and then you go to
Victorians o steampunky with blood-borne
yeah what kind of possibilities does it
open up
to go to like ancient Japan with that's
a good one take it off
yeah I know ja using Victorian diary
also a medieval dr. Eve
I do not Tim I got a tome on this you
know Konkani won't you for the day
Dona Tokyo gets tight on my mother's
name
mzingo cannot keep yeah but I need
updated all mothers she's only sort of
sense over you don't know what up
because I you don't know what up there
machinima besides Rebecca
so one of them that they wanted to
recreate it was it is set in the warring
States period which is a time of brutal
bloody civil war right and so that's a
it's a really intense period and that
was one thing that they didn't want to
recreate so they damn panel Quan Chi
Wang Lee Hom Crocker Ariana who K no
it's Krista so it had any more up at all
to say month the other thing that they
really wanted to create for this game
for this title that makes they wanted to
recreate the ancient beauty of Japan of
like the natural ancient beauty of Japan
like these and I can give some examples
I'm adding to what he said but there was
like you know imagine just huge temples
in the middle of a forest or you know
all these trees with beautiful fall
leaves on a bridge in the sunlight you
know what I mean so that type of imagery
as well is something that they're
looking to create can you talk it all
about that if we're gonna be leveling up
obviously a huge thing in Dark Souls and
and club owners collecting Souls and the
risk/reward of pushing forward but not
to lose things that you collected is
there gonna be any kind of mechanic like
that Jono whatever up to God I don't
think you know how much with all this
canary whose name I'm not sure did you
know in this kid Oman them for tomorrow
it's mundial de determinar theater so
perfectly could be noticed at all so
intimate a bit slow mo came to see us
right so in terms of progression and
getting stronger so in in the past they
would use a stat system you know add
points to strengths etc they're actually
doing something different than that this
time we can't go into a huge amount of
detail on it but that was the first
thing he said there no no they're not a
ballgame austere tequila toasted non
locker or or get dose there
in German Nazi Oh cannot equip Kokua
fonseca devil cause the anonymous all
right that said the feeling of beating
enemies getting something from them
getting stronger and stronger still
there yeah this penalty comes em all
mother Kareem Ali toxic abdominal cavity
there tonight to another player
concavity no more mcconkle matzah gotta
cover today no Thomas indeed alligator
two minutes and as for the penalty for
death that is also going to be very
different this time we can't really talk
about what it is but that feeling of
dreading dying is going to be there in a
completely different way so as we're
making our way through the game is it
going to be more of an open path like
we're used to like exploring there's not
really a set critical path that we have
to follow you're surely with the the
grappling hook and the increased
traversal I mean that players could
technically take on any boss in any
order who wears the limit
let's let's get yesterday's answer so
know much of the freedom no don't don't
let June bang dick Christ a good cut to
you Hannah she got a risk at all just
throw a cunzhen e Jesus come on Oh such
corrupt or an almost immortal Serena on
the spot yes CMS name I know
boy so do we are too great a beautiful
to run there
oh no oh my gosh my avocado mamas Bosnia
twas a canine disk at the wall massage
up Cara a good scar avocado commercially
a nice item up knocks on a very kebab
business I know Madonna's Jakob at
zero-nine desk a dome or an Oprah yoga
Junie I know cinco security anonymous so
if you had to draw a comparison to what
the world structure is like it's
probably closest to the way that they
laid out Dark Souls 1 right just that
you have all of these interconnected
areas with multiple paths between them
so it's not but that said it's not like
you could just access all the paths from
the start right there will be there's
player choice and how you complete the
game but there is you know as well order
in those choices if that makes sense
so there's certain milestones you kind
of have to hit in a sort a certain order
but there are paths between the
milestones that you can mix and match up
I'd say that sounds pretty accurate too
let me double check with them no Tom I
just don't go up there I know so no
matter stone altar sister zucchini or
Aikido bachelor kaitos ready to concoct
let's call it or image toast we need sky
to avoid a snare no tomorrow Cory cats
critique women about the hangover are
conversational they're holed up outside
the United State all hi-yah so not 100%
finals so you can't say for sure of
course but that is that is kind of what
the general image that they have right
now yes for me today and almost all
states absolutely will not type in
Okemah to put together my life but that
said it's not like okay we're on this
map we got to kill this boss we kill
them we get a cut scene tells us what to
do now we're on to boss - right it's
there's all it's a lot more open than
that yep you know it's like making games
that traditionally don't hold your hand
even though it seems like in the modern
landscape a lot of games feel the need
to is that something that from software
like sounds like that's something that
you want to keep avoiding it's if
telling players exactly where to go
especially if sake euro is similar to
Dark Souls which is probably the least
hand-holding in any of the Dark Souls
titles right I know yeah buddy I know
this is good okay you don't know wha no
isn't know that that they are I don't
suck at it at home on the sky I'm also
no consciousness today so listen a party
jibon the tanzaku stare al character on
a model you zoom in the optical hoodies
on their tonsils demos Jeannie Jeannie
Tara Danny garden that all the conga
tunnels India I don't know pianos yeah
you know that it's really what makes the
exploration fun is when you feel like
you're the one exploring so that's kind
of been their philosophies just let
players explore the world and and find
things on their own and have that happen
organically
rather than being very heavy-handed mom
Katara's image cannot cannot pick that
up
Monica yeah bye Tiki guy - taka so it
all okay more Punk are you is she doing
there atashi [ __ ] you got him it's a
no meat eaters calm
in there so if you like for example if
you were to find a secret path
you know let's say you're walking down
here like I think this is a secret I'm
gonna check this out and then you run
into something horrifying that you did
not expect to see that's that's an
interesting experience and they like
that kind of gameplay one of the things
that Dark Souls and blood-borne had
words the online multiplayer aspect
where you could leave notes for other
players are we gonna have any like any
type of that go on Omaima Marnell
because the sword is they are denoted to
go go go study it on the Smithsonian or
Doris car so this nakiya machine guru
play their nickyloo Tony to'kustar are
no single production auto bench armies
are sit there no they're its own line
your sake no no very say night game
anonymous so this summer around we made
the conscious decision to focus
specifically on the single-player
experience so we're actually you don't
have any online features at all that's
quite surprising but it's very
interesting move I would say yeah yeah
more actually there's there's a pretty
cool reasons for it if we have time I
don't know yeah yeah I know
ja so no well almost be curious they are
almost ready to fire ja so Mohan Joshi
much okano
does a single penny process name
apollyon or Thomas is not a spear no
game at a single player game a tocar
mother single pretty more you know we
don't across oh man I totally magician
got across Ohio star game at all cons
any single piano game at the beginning
is anger people come up to code in this
owner high so you know when you design a
multiplayer game versus a single-player
game a lot of things are different
additionally when okay hold on sorry
it's early in the morning get my second
at my brain a second to catch up with
that alright alright so when you a
design animal player game versus a
single player game it's a very different
a different way to go about it there's a
lot of different things you have to
consider when you do so the same thing
goes for using multiple classes right so
if you're doing a multiplayer game with
multiple
you know a whole multiple classes you
have to consider okay a knight has to be
able to beat this boss and a mage has to
be able to beat this boss and also they
both have to beat this to be able to
beat this boss if they can someone one
another and there's a lot of
considerations you have to make if you
go to single-player it really changes
the limitations or I should say I mean
both have limitations but it's a
different set of limitations that you
can work with in a different way in a
really interesting way for these guys
this time I added a little bit on the
end there
okay Sudan dr. more singularity Stoker
I know could a cigar no more sorry no
muscle tone is Kamal Konkani constable
at or a notional be no single a nice you
just apply to initial we can either talk
custom Elizabeth right so you know they
love multiplayer games they love
single-player games and they decided
that it would be really interesting if
they could focus on being a ninja and
taking that as and seeing how far they
could take that and see where they could
go with it so that was was it so just
keeping a single player like open up a
wider array of possibilities would you
say yeah none of the jock Colonels
saying uh-oh Grenada to Callisto home
matter to God my God all this all this
in a boom box crew you got them all not
single appearance turbulent I already is
on a single be no naka there you know we
know what about the key to be finished
short that's exactly it yeah there's as
a if it's a single-player game and
you're a single class there's a lot more
options you can create for that single
class so she's not taking more classes
ducking ultimate ice did Joe's team will
take you must apply it and you can also
tune for that tune everything for that
one class and it allows for a lot of
possibilities there yep how long has the
team been working on the game I had to
pick your daughter Scott Hudson
Commodore I Stephenson high hats guns
Don toño Chicano non tonic or game modes
croakie la caja scimitar oh ah oh no
bruh come on no Don LaFontaine trauma
whatever I know to get a snare right so
we can talk about development period
that they can tell you when they
initially got the idea for working on a
Japanese game yeah there was a they
first started thinking Japan was a cool
idea around blood-borne you'll see
around that timing did you say awesome
well Robert and Yasuhiro thank you so
much for joining us on stage thank you
any inkling of when people might be able
to expecting the sacred oh yeah early
2019 awesome yeah well thank you can't
wait they help you will have a great
rest of the show and everybody if you're
watching from home we will be right back
with skullenbones to stick around
you